شارع هادئ مخصص للمشاه فقط مقاهين صغيره
تنتشر هنا وهناك لا يزال يعقوب يتحدث عن
مدينته المنكوبه بصيغه الحاضر
يهوى الرجل التصوير قبل يوم من الزلزال
وبينما الثلج يتساقط وثقت الساعات الاخيره
قبيل الفاجعه
هكذا كان احد اشهر الفنادق في اديامان
وهكذا اصبح
كان هناك طلاب من قبرص الشماليه علقوا تحت
الانقاض اتت فرق انقاذ وحاولت انتشالهم
حاولنا ايضا المساعده
اذن انهيار الفندق الى مقتل اكثر من 100
شخص بينهم طلاب في فريق للكره الطائره من
قبرص الشماليه قتل الفريق باكمله تحت
انقاذ هذا المبنى حاولنا العثور على اي
اثر تركه الضحايا خلفهم الدمار اخفى كل
شيء لكنه لم يمحو ذكراهم فتلك باقيه في
قلوب عائلتهم الحزن جاوز حدود تركيا
نجحنا في التواصل مع عائلتي احد الطلاب
فقدنا 35 شخصا من فماجستا الجميع واقرباء
واصدقاء نعيش كارثه وكان قنبله نوويه
القيت علينا
على وقع الم الخساره الكبير استعادت عائله
الطلاب جثامنهم انتشلتهم فرق البحث من تحت
الانقاض اقيمت الصلاه عليهم في اديمان ثم
نقل جوا الى قبرص ليدفنوا قرب عائلاتهم
قصه تلخص حاله كثيرين تزامن وجودهم في
تركيا مع وقوع الزلزال ولم تكتب لهم
النجاه
سلام خضر الجزيره اديما
[موسيقى]